What exactly is queen sans
The queen sans
Is from the word frances which means
Rebirth
This is also the season
With the resurgence of cultural changes
During this same period
Classicals restored
Grassia culture
At Roma
It existed from the fourteenth to the eleventh
Six centuries
The queen sans
gave way
With many changes in the field of art
Arquitectura
and sculpture
Became
Merchants also inspired the queen sans
Because it became prosperous
The economy
In the field of
Exploration
Encouraged by the queen
Sans the travelers
Placer of the world
It is a time when the
interest
of citizens
In human nature
And caused by it
Meet people with abilities
In different fields
Moments that gave way to the queen sans
The queen sans began when
Thirteen Fifties
In northern cities
Italian state
It reached the peak of popularity
When fifteen hundred
Italy was born to queen sans
For many reasons
The cities are
This state for a long time he dominated
On the way of trade
Between the east
and west
Europa and the middle east
By
Thirteen hundred
The cities
That it became the richest city in Europa
Italy
It is well located in the field of trade
The structure
Of northern Italy
Has helped to spread the wealth of trade
The region is divided into many independents
City
state
The growing trade
Has brought new wealth
In these cities
That the most important is venice
Florence milan and junowa
In four cities
The so-called venice
adratic queen
Thepinakamakapangyarihan
The florence and the medizy
The florence is recognized as the symbol of queen san
In Italy
Similar to ancient attens
Those are shaped here
Considered writer
The art man
Architect
Scholar scholar
And scientists
In just a short time
Lorenzo is the most popular of the medcs
Known as the
Magnificent
Who died when
Fourteen ninety two
He reflected the idea of queen sans
A politician at heart
He holds the florence in times of emergency
He was also admired as a generous patron
of art
So the palace of medcs
Always visited by writers and philosophers
The
Statue in the garden of the palace of the metisi
Served as a role model
of michael angelo
The new idea and art
Humanism
One of the
Element of queen san in italia the movement that if
Call it humanism
or humanism
Humanism is a mental system
Or action with a vested interest
of man
It had a big impact
In Europa
The yumanisms paid attention to the person
yumanism has many meanings
In the time of queen sans
In the beginning
The yumanism
Is a study of the classical literature
And language
For the reason that the ancient Romans
Are the ancestors of the Italians
The yumanists marveled at the gresia
At Roma
as a model
In all aspects of life
This is the queen sans